diez de nosotros hemos sido secuestrados
por aliens porque piensan que somos una
muestra representativa de la raza humana
lo que van a hacer es probarnos para ver
si la raza humana merece formar parte de
la alianza intergaláctica de los
planetas y si no somos lo
suficientemente buenos
entonces nos van a exterminar a todos y
van a convertir el planeta en una granja
gigante de hongos y de hongos porque eso
es lo que utilizan como petróleo
entonces nos juntan a todos en su nave
espacial y nos dicen ustedes representan
a la humanidad y el destino de la
humanidad está en sus manos vamos a
ponerles una prueba y la prueba es la
siguiente mañana justo 24 horas a partir
de ahorita vamos a meterlos a todos en
un cuarto oscuro formando una fila uno
detrás de otro voy a ver si puedo
dibujar la situación aquí está la primer
personita este de aquí es la persona que
queda hasta enfrente y se ve un poquito
preocupada verdad bueno alguien me dijo
que era el borroso de las matemáticas
entonces pensé que sería una buena idea
hacer un poco del trabajo que hace beau
cross o sea a dibujar aquí tiene su
corbata
este es el primero de nosotros como sea
entonces él está viendo hacia esta
dirección y hay 10 más de estos en vez
de volver a dibujar voy a copiar y pegar
esta imagen todos nos vemos
misteriosamente similares entre sí el
segundo y el tercero de hecho hay diez
de estos voy a hacer uno más y voy a
pegar hasta acá ok
bueno ya con esto está bien hay diez de
nosotros y esencialmente estamos
formando una fila de modo que pues él
sólo puede ver las nucas de estas dos
personas y el de en medio a ver déjame
mejor dibujo una inclinación para que
entiendas un poquito más porque ve a los
dos el piso está más o menos así un
poquito inclinado de modo que este es
uno este es otro este es otro éste es
otro acá hay diez de éstos todos están
viendo en esta dirección hacia la
izquierda el primero sólo puede ver la
pared vale pero éste ve a los dos de
enfrente éste ve al que está enfrente de
él y hay diez de ellos así siguiendo
hacia atrás pero bueno lo que nos dicen
es que nos van a formar en una fila así
y nos hacen el diagrama bien padre y
todo porque pues realmente si quieren
que la tierra se una a la alianza
planetaria entonces nos dicen lo
siguiente cuando esté todo todo todo
oscuro vamos a ponerle un sombrero a
cada uno de ustedes que va a tener uno
de dos colores puede que el sombrero sea
ya sea morado como este de aquí o bien
que el sombrero sea color pues digamos
color verde ok entonces aquí tenemos un
color verde ahora hay algo importante
estos sombreros de aquí están diseñados
de tal forma de que el sombrero no lo
puedes ver tú o sea por más que intentes
esto es tecnología alien de punta
entonces no vas a poder ver tu sombrero
va lo siguiente que nos dicen es que los
colores de los sombreros van a estar
asignados aleatoriamente es decir podría
ser que tocara que todos fueran verdes o
no sé que a lo mejor todos fueran
morados o que toquen tres morados y
siete verdes o mitad y mitad no sabemos
ni siquiera los alien los van a elegir
va a ser totalmente aleatorio ya con los
sombreros y esto no lo van a decir a
todos van a empezar con la persona de
hasta atrás a ver voy a hacer otro
dibujo
pero ahora si te voy a quedar mal con
los de bomberos está la pared el piso
aquí está la persona 1 la persona 2 la
persona 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10
todos estamos volteando hacia la
izquierda entonces van a empezar con
este monito de hasta atrás al que estoy
circulando lo que van a hacer es
preguntarle cuál es el color de tu
sombrero después de eso él va a intentar
responder la pregunta pero un detalle él
nada más puede responder morado o verde
y también tengo que decirte otra cosa
que es particularmente importante cuando
diga si es morado o verde tiene que
decirlo con un tono neutral pero
suficientemente fuerte para que todos lo
podamos oír a lo que me refiero con los
del tonos neutrales que él solo puede
comunicar si cree que tiene un sombrero
verde o morado sin embargo todos vamos a
poder escucharlo incluso el de hasta
adelante o sea todos podemos escuchar
todo pues ahora sí este monito latina y
dice tengo un sombrero morado y en
efecto es morado por ejemplo entonces él
y las 600 millones de personas que
representan el mundo van a sobrevivir y
sus casas no se van a convertir
por otro lado si no le atina
inmediatamente lo van a cómo se dice
esto de las películas así lo van a
desintegrar y en ese mismo instante van
a evaporar a todos los que representa y
van a convertir sus casas en granjas de
hongos como puedes ver todos nosotros
debemos estar súper motivados para
obtener la respuesta correcta ok
siguiendo con la historia nos dicen
vamos a hacerles esto mañana y su
objetivo por supuesto es salvar a la
mayor cantidad de vidas posibles ahorita
los vamos a llevar a un spa y tratarlos
bien pero en 24 horas deben de haber
discutido la estrategia que usarán esta
estrategia debe de servir para que
cuando nos pongamos en el cuarto obscuro
y les pongamos los sombreros a cada uno
de ustedes sin creo que no debería
dibujar sombreros cafés a ver verde tras
ponerles los sombreros y prender la luz
así esto es algo que no te había dicho
después de que nos pongan los sombreros
van a prender la luz ya que está
prendida la luz van a empezar con la
ronda de preguntas van a preguntarle al
de hasta atrás de qué color es su
sombrero y obviamente él no va a saber
pero va a poder ver los sombreros de
todos los demás de modo similar el
penúltimo no va a poder ver ni su
sombrero ni el de hasta atrás lo bueno
es que va a haber escuchado lo que dijo
él
y puede ver todos los sombreros de
adelante entonces una vez que prenden la
luz le preguntan al de hasta atrás si
está en lo correcto vive y si no lo
desintegran después pasan al segundo y
misma idea si latina vive en él y sus
representados y si no los desintegran y
hacen granjas de hongos van a seguir así
sucesivamente hasta llegar al de
enfrente va entonces claramente nuestra
meta para salvar a la mayor parte de la
humanidad consiste salvar a la mayor
cantidad de nosotros esa es la parte
número uno del acertijo intentar salvar
a la mayor cantidad de nosotros pero
nada más para dejarlo bien claro lo
único que podemos responder cuando nos
preguntan es ya sea morado o verde sin
entonaciones raras ni nada eh no podemos
decir morado o morado para cargar más
información sólo podemos decir morado o
verde tampoco hay trucos ni nada
escondido no hay espejos ni miradas de
reojo ni nada los aliens son bien listos
y nos callan haciendo trampa abánades
integrarnos a todos ya convertir a la
tierra en una granja gigante de hongos
por ser tan deshonestos entonces esa es
la pregunta
tan solo viendo los sombreros y
escuchando lo que dicen los anteriores
cómo le podemos hacer para salvar a la
mayor cantidad de personas esa de ahí es
la pregunta del acertijo si quieres
puedes pausar ahorita el vídeo para
pensarlo tantito para intentar encontrar
una estrategia del acertijo y así va a
partir de ahorita ya vamos a empezar con
un poquito de sugerencias bueno esta no
es una sugerencia tan importante porque
no te va a decir gran cosa de la
estrategia la sugerencia es la siguiente
a lo mejor sea fácil llegar a algunas
estrategias que salven pues unas cuantas
personas sin embargo la mera mera
estrategia así la mejor cita de todas va
a poder salvar a nueve de nosotros sale
entonces esta es una nueva meta para el
problema si quieres encontrar la
estrategia la mejor de todas tienes que
encontrar alguna que permita salvar a
nueve de nosotros a partir de aquí
seguiré con sugerencias y finalmente con
la solución otra vez es un buen momento
para pausar el vídeo van a ser las
primeras nueve personas de estas
personas podemos garantizar que las
salvamos y el último pues obviamente va
a estar adivinando este que está hasta
el final de la fila no le queda de otra
aunque pueda ver a todos los de enfrente
no tiene ni tío de info
pasión para saber algo acerca de su
sombrero así diga lo que diga tiene
probabilidad de un medio de atinar ya su
sombrero pues el 50 por ciento de las
veces tendrá un sombrero verde y el otro
50% un sombrero morado de este modo se
salva la mitad de las veces y la mitad
no y por tanto el número esperado de
personas que salvamos va a ser 9.5 claro
asumiendo que podemos salvar a los nueve
de enfrente pero como le podemos hacer
para que esto sea que los nueve días
está enfrente garanticemos que se pueden
salvar queremos que se salven el 100 por
ciento de las veces ahora hay algunos
argumentos probabilísticos interesantes
si quieres detener el vídeo para pensar
los por tu cuenta
por ejemplo este bonito de hasta atrás
puede ver que tantos sombreros hay
enfrente de él y que tantos sombreros
morados hay enfrente de él entonces
cuando le hagan la pregunta lo que va a
responder es de lo que vea más por
ejemplo si enfrente de seis morados y
tres verdes entonces cuando le pregunten
va a decir morado ahora es posible que
se salve o que no pero bueno se salve o
no se salve ya le comunicó a los demás
que de lo que hay más es morado así en
vez de decir algo aleatoriamente pues
conviene un poquito más
y morado ahora si todos dicen morado con
esto logramos salvar a 6 personas y esto
es una estrategia posible bueno ok nada
mal pues está decente verdad con esto
aseguramos salvar a la mayoría de los
nueve y por lo tanto siempre salvamos al
menos a cinco personas con un poco de
suerte suben como a siete oa ocho otro
método es tomar almas no sabes qué mejor
le dejamos hasta aquí de otros métodos y
pasamos al bueno es que ya se está
alargando un poco el vídeo ahora sí inba
el método el mero mero entonces ahora sí
te recomiendo pausar el vídeo pensando y
regresar mañana para la respuesta el
monito que está hasta atrás va a ser lo
siguiente déjame hacer el dibujo voy a
poner aquí acá 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 sí
10 todos están ahorita con algún
sombrero pero lo que va a ser el de
hasta atrás dentro de 24 horas es lo
siguiente ahora no sabemos quién va a
quedar hasta atrás pero no importa nos
ponemos de acuerdo para que el que le
quede hasta atrás
entonces el que él quiere hasta tras lo
que va a hacer es contar todos los
sombreros a todos los sombreros verdes y
los sombreros morados que vea en frente
de él ok entonces agarra los ve y los
cuenta no importa quien quede atrás otra
vez los aliens nos van a poner en algún
orden pero el que quede hasta atrás va a
ser lo siguiente cuentan los sombreros
los sombreros verdes déjame ponerlo en
verde ok entonces cuentan los sombreros
en verde de hecho sólo con que cuente
los en verde está bien y va a ser lo
siguiente si ve que los verdes son una
cantidad impar entonces cuando vea que
haya una cantidad impar de sombreros
verdes enfrente de él lo que va a hacer
es decir a mi sombrero es verde verde
ok entonces lo que va a intentar
adivinar es que su sombrero es verde si
ve que el número de sombreros es par el
número de sombreros verdes cms es par
entonces lo que va a intentar adivinar
es que su sombrero es morado por
supuesto él no sabe si tiene un sombrero
verde o un sombrero morado pero bueno
número uno tiene un 50% de probabilidad
de salvarse pero ahora que sucede ahora
al dar esta información al resto de las
personas por gritar verde o morado
entonces pues no sé por ejemplo si él
dice mi sombrero es verde entonces el
penúltimo que es el siguiente que le van
a preguntar ahora sabe que la persona
que está detrás de si ve una cantidad
impar de sombreros verdes el de hasta
atrás de una cantidad impar de sombreros
verdes y esto está interesante porque o
sea si el penúltimo ve los verdes que
queda en frente de él y también ve una
cantidad y un par de sombreros
entonces eso quiere decir que él no
tenía uno de los sombreros verdes que
vio el último entonces él debe de tener
un sombrero morado
muy bien entonces él diría yo tengo un
sombrero morado y viviría va entonces
ahora vamos al siguiente no sabes qué
vamos a hacer el otro caso supongamos
que el penúltimo tiene bueno o sea que
el de hasta atrás dice verde lo cual
quiere decir que vio una cantidad impar
de sombreros verdes y ahora el penúltimo
ve que hay una cantidad par con
sombreros verdes entonces ahora lo que
tiene que hacer es deducir que él tiene
un sombrero verde para que cambie la
paridad y tiene y entonces va a decir
verde va a estar en lo correcto y
también se salva ahora el antepenúltimo
hace algo similar
ahora vamos a tomar la situación en la
cual éste tiene un sombrero morado el
penúltimo entonces el primero de una
cantidad impar verdad él grita verde
luego el segundo o bueno el penúltimo
también ve una cantidad de impar porque
pues él no tiene un sombrero verde él
dice morado sobrevive y entonces el
antepenúltimo pues depende del caso
verdad o sea como el penúltimo dijo
morado y vivió verdad o sea o sabemos
que viven porque los aliens nos dicen
que que sobrevivió pero
el antepenúltimo sabe que el penúltimo
vio una cantidad impar de sombreros
después de él en adelante porque él no
dijo verde dijo morado entonces como él
vio una cantidad impar pues él nada más
tiene que ver ahora a los que le siguen
sin una cantidad par de sombreros de
verde entonces él puede deducir que a él
le toca sombrero verde y sobreviviría de
este modo si este cuate tiene un
sombrero verde entonces osea el primero
había una cantidad impar de sombreros
verdes verdad de ahí en adelante luego
uno de estos bonitos o sea a china me
estoy hacen un poquito de bolas pero
cada vez que alguien diga verde antes de
ti eso quiere decir que el número de
sombreros verdes que son pares o impares
enfrente de esa persona va a cambiar
entonces pues hay que llevar esto en
esta cuenta en la cabeza cada vez que
alguien dice verde es porque ya pasó un
sombrero verde sabes que mejor déjame
darte un ejemplo voy a dibujar uno
es no sabes que de hecho vamos a hacerlo
con un color neutral para que no estemos
tras tanto tiempo verde morado morado
verde verde morado verde verde ya
llevamos ocho personas morado y morado
ok entonces la estrategia es la
siguiente el último se va a fijar en
cuántos sombreros verdes hay enfrente
del 1 2 3 4 5 ok
como elvio 5 sombreros verdes
los verdes son una cantidad de impar
entonces él va a decir que su sombrero
es verde este es el sistema que
inventamos él va a decir a mi sombrero
es verde pero el buster va a estar en lo
equivocado lo van a desintegrar para
mejorar los aliens le dan chance si
salvamos a todos los demás pero digamos
que lo eliminamos como dijo verde ahora
todos estos monitos bueno saben que el
vio una cantidad de impar en particular
el penúltimo ahora puede ver que hay 1 2
3 4 5 sombreros verdes todavía y como
todavía son 5 una cantidad de impar eso
quiere decir que su sombrero no puede
ser verde porque si no cambiaría la
variedad de la cantidad de sombreros a
partir de ese momento de sombreros
verdes entonces él no tiene un sombrero
verde dice tengo un sombrero morado y
por lo tanto sobrevive muy bien ahora
vamos con el penúltimo con el
antepenúltimo cuenta que hay uno dos
tres cuatro sombreros verdes ahora que
sucede pues
ahora solo veo una cantidad par de
sombreros en el anterior a me dio una
cantidad impar
entonces yo debo de tener un sombrero
verde muy bien palomita latina ahora qué
pasa con el anterior puede saber él sabe
cuántos verdes vio el bueno no cuántos
pero sabe que vio una cantidad par de
sombreros por qué porque este monito dio
una cantidad o sea si él hubiera visto 5
hubiera dicho impar entonces no puede
haber visto 5 pero él sólo ve 3 verdad
este monitor que le toca solo ve tres
sombreros verdes de modo que él debe de
ser uno de los sombreros verdes dice
verde y también se salva ahora qué pasa
con el anterior pues misma idea como el
anterior dijo impar y él también ve una
cantidad impar pues no puede ser que
pues él tenga un sombrero verde porque
cambiaría la paridad y misma idea como
sólo ve tres que son verdes el mío no
puede ser verde de modo que es morado y
latina y así podemos seguir y seguir
hasta que llegamos al primer hito y
todos estos de aquí van a contestar
correctamente porque siempre saben un
acerca de la
edad de los sombreros que vio el
anterior y todos los anteriores ahora
quizás el primero no se salva ojalá los
aliens le den chance espero que te haya
gustado es de mis acertijos favoritos si
aquí estuvo un poco confuso haciendo
todos los casos acá arriba creo que con
el ejemplo estuvo mejor ya con esto
quedó un poco más clara la estrategia
solo espero no haberse confundido mucho
escribiendo verde y morado en color azul
nos vemos hasta la próxima